cela fait des années que l'on voit ces
images de vancouver et pourtant elles
font toujours partie du quotidien
tous les lundis je reçois un courriel
pour me dire combien de personnes sont
mortes d'une surdose au cours de la
semaine dernière dit le maire hier il y
en avait neuf est
possible de trouver un vancouvérois
qu'ils ne soient pas touchés
personnellement par ses statistiques
ajoutent ils
pour faire face à la crise la ministre
fédérale des dépendances et de la santé
mentale temps cette exemption à son
homologue britanno-colombienne à compter
du mois de janvier et pour les trois
prochaines années quiconque possède pour
un usage personnel 2,5 g d'opioïdes de
cocaïne des méthamphétamines ou
d'ecstasy en colombie britannique ne
sera ni arrêté ni accusés et les
substances ne seront pas saisie
l'objectif est de ne plus traiter les
problèmes de dépendance comme un crime
mais comme une maladie c'est une bonne
nouvelle le détail de l'application de
cette nouvelle initiative
sera déterminante en termes de son
succès ou de son échec le docteur brian
conway et directeur de la clinique des
maladies infectieuses de vancouver selon
lui pour que la décriminalisation donne
des résultats il faut s'assurer que les
consommateurs soient pris en charge et
on ouvre la porte à la déstigmatisation
d'une part et à l'implication de ces
gens là dans des systèmes de soins
l'association canadienne des chefs de
police a milité en faveur de l'exemption
mais prévient que seule la mesure ne
suffira pas pour réduire le nombre de
décès
ça prendra davantage de lits un meilleur
accès au site d'injection supervisée et
à des substances sécuritaire bravo pour
les gens colombie-britannique mes yeux
des morts partout au pays pour le
néo-démocrate alexandre boulerice le
gouvernement doit aller plus loin et
plus vite le npd a déposé un projet de
loi pour étendre la décriminalisation
partout au canada ont vu depuis des
années une grave crise des opioïdes tous
les intervenants sur le terrain nous
disent on l'a
montrez pas question pour la ministre
bennett de décriminaliser d'un bout à
l'autre du pays mais maintenant que la
colombie britannique a créé le modèle
elle est ouverte à accorder d'autres
exemptions une à la fois innovation
du mot quoi c'est donc une première mais
ottawa ne ferme déjà pas la porte à
accorder d'autres exemptions même si
pour l'instant santé canada est
incapable de dire combien de surdoses
pourront être évités et combien de vies
pourront être sauvées grâce à cette
mesure et si valérie gamache radio
canada ottawa